marc-antoine le bret qui est avec nous
vous le savez la semaine dernière on a
accueilli une nouvelle chroniqueuse
elle est belle elle est sexy et son
arrivée a énormément fait parler c'est
bien sûr elle faisait là là
et les malades chroniques au succès elle
t'excite à la gendarmerie garder la bave
aux lèvres et le slip qui rétrécit a vu
deux
il étonne que tu as cru que j'avais fait
les films les olé j'ai tellement d irak
était petit menée dans une scène elle
devient torride sénat si j'ai une
tragédie grecque s être directement sur
you part je veux dire qu'avec moi
j'exprimerai molière ça devient
carrément du jackie et michel on est
relégué merci des chiens émollient
réserve de mercy d'agenda ici je suis à
présent on peut on penser plus à dallas
nabila dont les propos sur la télé
réalité ont fait réagir à nos confrères
matthieu delormeau
ça vous a un petit peu garder mathieu
oui eh ben nabila des parts on excuse
parce que je suis rancunier
j'arrive au bout des divisions biens et
vos goûts
un témoignage qui continue comme ça la
vie là je retourne vers 4 heures de
muscu benoit tu en penses quoi
la raison benoît alors vous taisez et la
villa tu me fais chier
voilà ça c'est fait merci monsieur qui
bat edouard mokolo boîte et puis
week-end dernier
alors le week-end dernier on a l'a dit
pour coup de main dans cette émission
ils avaient danse avec les stars et on
c'était l'occasion de revoir jean marc
généreux
alors jean marc loranger l'hérault
j'aimerais ça parce que ce que pense
jean marc généreux de nos deux nouvelles
recrues ça te dit nouvelles
chroniqueuses je les ai dit nabila son
décolleté il est comme moi et les
généreux et là dessous c'est pareil
j'adore je leur mets plus j'étais rocco
siffredi je le remettrais intrants
touche pas à mon poste c'est génial
c'est qu'un an khanh allemands qu'à
l'âge légal
les choux
oui ni la chute pas très contents qu'ils
soient sur le plateau de touche pas à
mon poste c'est un grand comédien qui
voulait donner son avis sur notre équipe
c'est vincent cassel
écoutez moi qu'est-ce qu'il ya quand
même là pourquoi ça m'occupe à al houla
pas ou quoi
avec les mecs le monde mais que je
m'occupe pas se mouiller ou par non les
manipulent par là ok je te réponds alors
bon hanouna là pour faire ton émission
là d'après un chroniqueur beau gosse un
spirituel inquiet cultiver bon si tu
voulais faire des économies avec un
prendre moi ouais moi tout seul parce
que moi je suis tout ça à la fois
ouais je me kiffe fois et alors
alors il ya quelqu'un aussi calmes un
petit mot à dire sur les chroniqueurs de
touche pas à mon poste et stéphane bern
bouge
écoutez je dois le dire que j'apprécie
conditionnement nouvelles chroniqueuses
force m'est de confesser un petit faible
pour julien cause
je trouve aussi talentueux que
magnétique d'ailleurs cyril cela fait
belle lurette qu'elles vous dis qu'il
doit être très bien au sein d'une bande
et que pour tout dire j'ai envie de voir
bande et pardonnez moi julien je vous ai
lapsus est cocasse c'est quasiment un
truculent
bon je vous ai je cru qu'une d'ailleurs
si j'avance et je recule
comment veux tu comment veux tu que je
truc du lit pour terminer vendredi
c'était la fin de secret story on allait
il a en plus avec nous comment vous
rassure mais comment vous résumeriez
votre dernière saison benjamin castaldi
bonjour à tous alors je dois dire que
c'est grey story ça c'est vraiment fini
sur les chapeaux de roue vous vous dire
que cette année dans la maison des
secrets on s'est battu comme des chiens
mais gilles on a aussi vu des couples
qui ont roucoulé balancer des noms
d'oiseaux cube bien au final que c'était
une belle saison la vache mais on
pourrait résumer cette saison en
quelques mots je dirais que vous mmes
seydoux
il fallait voir au coin des rues la
vraie bref aller voir son spectacle il
est excellent bravo je vais voir tous à
côté moi sérieuse je n'en peux plus